sie stellen die kleinste fraktion im
bundestag und wollen trotzdem ins
kanzleramt die grünen hatten bis vor
kurzem einen höhenflug doch dann häuften
sich im wahlkampf die fehler der
spitzenkandidatin und der partei stehen
die grünen sich selbst im weg und wer
bringt sie wieder auf kurs darüber rede
ich heute mit robert habeck dem co
vorsitzenden der grünen hier in
wassersleben bei flensburg herzlich
willkommen zum zdf sommerinterview
[Musik]
hallo herr haben morgen willkommen in
facebook willkommen beim zdf
sommerinterview wir sind ja streng
geheimen wassersleben und nicht gedreht
doch grob gesehen flensburg links von
uns denn das was der ganze hört mit
brücke ja alles ziemlich nah beieinander
hier und trotzdem weit das steht
zumindest in ihrem profil auf der grünen
website das steht ganz oben bei ihrer
jugend lebensbeschreibung sie kommen
hier aus dieser region
hier ist der horizont weit und die
menschen geerdet wie oft brauchen sie
das eigentlich im moment dieser
atmosphäre hier um dich zu verzweifeln
über den von berggruen wahlkampf naja
das eine hat mit dem anderen nichts zu
tun das ist schon heimat hier für mich
die menschen wie die landschaft und der
grüne wahlkampf hatte ein paar probleme
aber ist überhaupt das gegenteil von dem
was sie gesagt haben und ich freue mich
auf den august im september er hatte
probleme vor allem jetzt zuletzt im
saarland
da frage ich mich jetzt aktuell hat sich
ihre grüne partei so zerstritten auf
landesebene dass sie mit einer
landesliste nicht mal zur bundestagswahl
antreten darf was wählt da jetzt
eigentlich ein grünes parteimitglied mit
der zweitstimme für eine partei
tja das ist wirklich eine bescheidene
situation für uns erst mal die aufgabe
die stimmen die deutlich eingesammelt
werden können zu verdoppeln darstelle
einzusammeln zum beispiel hier im norden
meinen wahlkreis hier wahlkreis 1 ist so
groß wie das saarland
also muss ich dafür sorgen dass wir die
30 50 70 tausend stimmen verloren haben
in teilen hier kompensieren aber auch
die situation würde ich gerne gleich
noch mal mit ihnen darüber weiterreden
aber die uhr im sitzen bitte stehen und
sitzen wie sie wollen
herr beck das thema saarland sie haben
gerade schon gesagt das ist eine
bescheidene situation und sie haben
beschrieben wie sie das wieder
rausreißen wollen dass sie da jetzt gar
keine stimmen für die partei über die
landesliste bekommen können aber die
frage ist ja auch was haben sie im
vorfeld eigentlich getan um diesen
riesen hockt in ihre partei da
geschossen hat zu verhindern
offensichtlich nicht genug das ist ja
klar keine gute situation war viele
analysen helfen jetzt auch nicht weiter
deswegen muss das was da im wald nicht
möglich ist einzusammeln ein anderer
stelle eingesammelt werden also ich
wiederhole mich da an der stelle die
aufgabe ist jetzt nach vorne zu schauen
und einen entschieden den entschlossenen
und erfolgreichen wahlkampf an den rest
republik die ja noch groß genug ist so
weit sind sie denn mal hinfahren oder
jemand anders frau berbalk vielleicht
oder jemand aus der parteizentrale
wir hatten immer wieder kontakt mit dem
saarland aber offensichtlich haben wir
es nicht geschafft und die saarländer
auch nicht wir hätten dann ja vielleicht
an anderer stelle unterstützen können
das problem war vorher frühzeitig zu
lösen
aber nochmal das ist jetzt alles
vergossene milch jetzt muss nach vorne
geschaut werden es ist ärgerlich genug
also müssen wir sehen dass wir an
anderer stelle
ich frage deshalb nach weil sie mit
einem so unglaublich hohen anspruch in
diesen wahlkampf reingehen sie sagen ja
jetzt geht es um alles in dieser
schicksalswahl
und sie wollen als grüne im prinzip
deutschland die größte wirtschaftsnation
europas komplett umkrempeln
wirtschaftlich und gesellschaftlich ganz
hoher anspruch an sich selbst dann
müsste doch die voraussetzung sein dass
sie so eine simple aufstellung einer
landesliste hinbekommen oder nicht ich
habe das schon jetzt glaube ich vier mal
gesagt ja das ist doof genug und
entsprechend ist die aufgabe weil ist so
wichtig ist ich werde warten die
entscheidung dass das saarland nicht die
grünen wählen kann ist zeitgleich
gewesen mit der nachricht dass der
golfstrom kollabiert das ist nämlich die
auf die aufgabe jetzt tatsächlich die
dringlichkeit umso größer zu machen und
den erfolg an anderen stellen deutlich
zu erhöhen ist ja mehr als doof ist
sieht jetzt so aus als ob sie auch schon
einfache sache nicht organisiert
bekommen dann ist die frage ob man ihnen
vertraut wenn sie deutschland
tatsächlich umorganisieren davon handelt
der wahlkampf dass wir deutlich machen
dass man uns vertrauen kann dass wir
anders als mit bewerbende parteien
wissen was die stunde geschlagen hat wie
dringlich die situation ist und die
maßnahmen dafür auch bereit haben
während
anderen sich in die büsche schlagen ihre
probleme haben aber ja nicht nur mit dem
saarland angefangen sie sind auch vorher
schon in den umfragen nach unten
gegangen
sie lagen mal kopf-an-kopf mitte union
teilweise sogar leicht davor das war im
frühjahr dann wurde ihre
kanzlerkandidatin nominiert nach einem
kurzen zwischenhoch sind sie dann
tatsächlich abgestürzt wer trägt
eigentlich dafür die verantwortung ich
würde die situation anders beschreiben
wir sind bei um die 20 gestartet dann
gab es dieses zwischenhoch gesinnte
wieder bei um die 20 klar wir hätten
auch woanders sein können aber wir haben
noch einmal eine sehr gute
ausgangsposition
die union hat eigene probleme wir sind
soweit nicht auseinander
alles ist möglich wir müssen jetzt sehen
dass wir deutlich machen und da scheint
ja wenn ich ein interview ich denke die
ich diese woche gegeben habe noch nicht
mal bei informierten journalismus
angekommen zu sein was die dringlichkeit
ist wie sich das wetter immer extremer
gebiert wie lieben und freiheit von
menschen in gefahr ist und dass wir
jetzt handeln müssen wenn man sich die
umfragen anschaut dann trauen die leute
vielleicht auch nicht zu mit dieser
dringlichkeit umzugehen kämpfen sie dann
trotzdem noch um platz eins wir sind bei
20 prozent ungefähr in den umfragen
wir kämpfen um ein möglichst starkes
ergebnis ermöglicht stark ist nach oben
offen werden wir gucken was daraus
passieren kann also die ausgangslage ist
ja im kern so sind wir bereit als
gesellschaft dem gefühl dass wir glaube
ich alle haben das ist fragil ist dass
wir eine zerbrechliche gesellschaft
geworden sind dass wir so nicht
weitermachen können auch konkrete
antworten
dann folgen zu lassen und wenn es uns
gelingt die debatte über die antworten
zu führen und nicht nur über ein
geregeltes über museen nicht zu viel
davon aber auch nicht zu wenig davon
und das soll dann politik sein dann
haben wir alle chancen bleiben wir
erstmal bei ihrer partei und schauen mal
wie und wo sie als grüne genau kämpfen
patricia wiedemeier hat dass man in
schweren 60 sekunden zusammen
es lief alles rund perfekt inszeniert
bis zur kür der kanzlerkandidatin liebe
anna lena bitte die bühne gehört die
schweren herzens muss habe ich ihr den
vortritt lassen dabei hätte er nichts
lieber gemacht als deutschland als
kanzler zu dienen wir später zugibt doch
wer bock macht einen fehler nach dem
anderen vergisst einkünfte dem bundestag
zu melden und ihren lebenslauf
darüber ärgere ich mich glaube ich am
meisten selbst sie weiß nicht dass sie
hier nicht im oderbruch steht sie
schreibt ein buch voller plagiate sie
wird zunehmend nervös die quittung
folgte prompt nach kurzzeitigen
höhenflug in den umfragen sinken die
grünen wieder auf etwa 20 prozent
aber auch harbeck sorgt für negative
schlagzeilen mit seiner forderung nach
rüstungsexporten in die ukraine und im
saarland wird nach parteiinternen
querelen die grüne landesliste nicht zur
bundestagswahl zugelassen
herr beck versucht im wahlkampf zu
retten was zu retten ist fügt sich in
seine rolle als mann hinter der burg
eine rolle die ihm nicht wirklich
gefallen dürfte er habe ich wenn sie
sich das so anschauen wie schwer ist das
eigentlich für sie der frau der sie
unterlegen sind jetzt beim scheitern
zuzuschauen und das ist die falsche
beschreibung und ich fühle mich auch gar
keine rolle ich habe eine rolle ist eine
rolle nämlich vollständig ausfüllt und
es ist eine gute rolle ich kämpfe für
ein starkes grünes ergebnis wobei
ehrlicherweise das grüne ergebnis ist
nur es geht gar nicht um die grünen
warum es geht darum dass die
gesellschaft entlang der analysen der
wirklichkeit handlungsfähig wird und das
sind wir nicht
und dafür bin ich in die politik
gegangen ich sehe die notwendigkeit ich
bin voll erfüllt mit der aufgabe und da
gibt es überhaupt keinen gar keine
abstriche zu machen gar nicht wenn sie
das so beschreibt in laage ähnlichkeit
der lage die haben sie jetzt schon ein
paar mal betont dass sie auch in der
rede im grünen wahlkampf geht es ja
quasi um alles bei ihnen geht es
buchstäblich ums überleben der
menschheit wenn das wirklich so ernst
ist müssen sie dann nicht sagen dann ist
jedes mittel recht um ins kanzleramt zu
kommen auch der austausch der
kanzlerkandidatin baerbock gegen einen
kanzlerkandidaten habe man das ist keine
debatte es geht darum dass der zustand
der gesellschaft gar nicht nur das klima
ist das klima ist letztlich das klima
wir hatten ja nicht das klima weil das
klima so schön sein sollte und der
zustand der gesellschaft
wir haben das nordrhein westfalen im
rheinland pfalz gesehen südeuropa brennt
wir haben temperaturen um die 50 grad in
kanada nordamerika gehabt das heißt dass
gegenmaßnahmen übergibt man einer person
und die verantwortung dafür ist eine
politische mehrheit zu erringen die
entsprechend der dringlichkeit der
situation handlungsfähig wird und dafür
kämpfen wir die politische mehrheit die
sie nach zahlen eher bekommen würden
wenn sie eine spitze stehen das sagen
zumindest die umfragen bei der
beurteilung nach sympathie und leistung
stehen sie auf nur drei plätze hinter
angela merkel
während frau berbalk im minusbereich
rangiert und 68 prozent der deutschen
sagen frau berbalk ist nicht geeignet
für das kanzleramt wann hatten sie denn
damals nicht den mut sich gegen die
frauen karte die frau berg gezogen hat
durchzusetzen ist geeignet fürs
kanzleramt und unsere aufgabe ist dafür
zu sorgen dass die grünen stark werden
und dann werden wir gucken was dabei
rauskommt wie stark wird werden sie
haben noch sieben wochen um da was
rauszuholen ist ja jetzt in ihrem
wahlkampf sehr viel von mut und
entschlossenheit freiburg hat gestern
und vorgestern anderen parteien
hasenfüßigkeit beim thema klima
vorgeworfen
das ist die umschreibung ich hatte
angebote gewählt die frage ist natürlich
auch bei ihnen wie viel mut haben sie
uns war nicht nur beim thema klima
sondern zum beispiel auch beim thema
corona jens spahn hat jetzt gerade die
debatte wieder belebt mit einem
vorschlag dass man ungeimpfte von
bestimmten aktivitäten ausschließt wenn
sie an die regierung kommen sollten
würden sie das tun oder nicht das geht
nicht darum ungeimpfte auszuschließen es
gibt die witterung geimpften ihre
grundrechte und ein freies leben
zurückzugeben beziehungsweise jetzt im
sommer geht's ja ganz gut dass auch im
winter und im herbst durchzuhalten
werden sie also eine antwort sie mit den
großen der ersten der das gesagt hat es
wird einen unterschied geben im zugang
von rechten und in der freiheit des
lebens zwischen münchen und umgehen und
zwar werden die geimpften so lange dass
die gesellschaft und das
gesundheitssystem tragen kann mehr
rechte haben das ist völlig eindeutig
das passiert automatisch ich habe
gestern einen schwerkranken menschen in
einem hospiz besucht und da durfte ich
nur rein wenn ich geimpft war das heißt
im geimpft werden da nicht rein gekommen
das entscheiden die privaten teilweise
selbst es gibt ganz automatisch in diese
richtung und das ist auch richtig so
man hat das recht sich nicht impfen zu
lassen aber
hatten nicht das recht dass alle
geimpften und der rest der gesellschaft
und die kinder dann rücksicht darauf
nehmen weil man sich selbst entschieden
hat sein eigenes leben und die
gesellschaft zu gefährden sie sind als
grüne im letzten jahr dafür kritisiert
worden dass sie zu viele maßen haben der
bundesregierung und der bundesländer
einfach mitgetragen haben sich oft
enthalten haben jetzt setzen sie sich
ein wenig ab winfried kretschmann hat
gerade zum thema impfpflicht gesagt im
extremfall jahr die bundesregierung
schließt dies kategorisch aus
sie sagen auch im extremfall jahr wand
denn diese extremfall ein
es gibt eine zusage der amtierenden
bundesregierung und der haben sich im
grunde alle anderen angeschlossenen das
nicht dass es keine impfpflicht gibt wir
haben auch bessere möglichkeiten das zu
tun im moment verfolgen wir noch eine
politik die menschen zum impfstoff zu
bringen wenn wir es mal umdrehen würden
den impfstoff zu den menschen zu bringen
das heißt niedrigschwellige angebote vor
den discountern vor vor den tafeln
beispielsweise im angebote zu machen
zu den schulen zu gehen dann würden wir
bessere quoten haben und diese mittel
sind ja noch gar nicht ausgeschöpft
und das ist der weg wenn wir eine grüne
regierung hätten wären dann eigentlich
wundert es weiterhin kostenlos ich bin
dafür dass die kostenlos bleiben auch
für nicht geben stellt ich halte diese
debatte wiederum an der stelle für
falsch es geht ja darum zu erkennen wo
das newroz ist jetzt liegt man die hürde
für diejenigen die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen aus gründen die ich falsch
finde höher
das heißt wir werden weniger wissen wo
sich das virus befindet und das ist eine
das ist die falsche maßnahme die leute
zum impfen zu motivieren die bessere
maßnahme ist diese den inneren
schweinehund mal einen kräftigen tritt
in den hintern zu geben also die diese
trägheit die wahrscheinlich ein gutteil
der menschen noch in sicherheit zu
überwinden indem man einfach sagt kommen
hier ist dass du kannst einfach dahin
gehen du kannst ja im voraus weiß
unterspritzt den arm und fertig richtig
an die nation kümmern
corona hat jetzt im vergangenen jahr
tatsächlich alles dominiert es gibt aber
weitere themen die eine kommende
bundesregierung erben wird vor allem
auch das thema migration
da sehen wir jetzt gerade wieder
bewegung in weißrussland das schickt ein
diktator geflüchtete richtung
europäische union das nachbarland
litauen reagiert mit gewalt auf das
ganze die grünen waren immer gegen
geschlossene außengrenzen der
europäischen union aber wenn sie sich
das angucken müssen sie dann nicht sagen
es geht tatsächlich nicht ohne zaun
litauen und europa hat das recht und die
notwendigkeit seine außengrenzen zu
schützen wir müssen wissen wer hat zu
uns auf den kontinent kommt umgekehrt
haben die menschen die nach die flucht
die gefürchtete sind und ein anspruch
auf asyl haben das recht diesen anspruch
in diesen asylantrag zu stellen
bitte geschlossene grenze jahr kann
sollte seine außengrenzen kontrollieren
und die menschen die dort sind müssen
registriert werden und dann beginnt das
europäische dilemma ist hart scheiterte
letztlich an verteilen mechanismus und
wenn wir das rundum machen in ganz
europa dann haben wir eine festung
europa spanien hatte das selbe problem
ganz kurz um das noch einmal kurz zu
ende zu bringen das problem ist dass
alle geflüchteten da sie dann zuerst in
litauen sind in litauen bleiben müssen
und deswegen ist es auch so allergisch
dagegen entsprechend griechenland
spanien usw
wenn wir ein anderes verteilsystem
hätten wenn wir das problem auch für
asylsuchende relativiert ich würde aber
sagen dass lukaschenko gemacht und das
bilderhaus macht ist das ausnutzen von
not und elend also eine humanitäre auf
asylstandards bestehende aber die
außengrenzen sich an der
flüchtlingspolitik darf sich auch nicht
erpressen dass man von einem diktator
wie belarus wie lukaschenko in belarus
und genau das passiert das heißt europa
ist vor allem gehalten mit dem irak zu
reden dass die flüchtlinge nicht als
faustpfand von diktator genommen werden
das geht so auch nicht die frage ist
dann wie geht man mit geflüchteten um
wenn sie hier sind da haben sie gerade
im fall afghanistan ganz klar stellung
bezogen sie sagen momentan sollte man
auf keinen fall mehr nach afghanistan ab
schieben grünen mitregierten
bundesländer handhaben das anders die
schieben fast alle weiterhin ab und
einige davon sagen auch davon dabei
wollen wir bleiben
die tatsache dass genannt die grünen
sagen das eine und das andere ist das
doppelmoral
nein das ist es nicht ich habe ja auch
gesagt dass der lagerbericht des
auswärtigen amtes korrigiert werden muss
wir sind ja ein rechtsstaat die
abschiebung erfolgen auf einer
lageeinschätzung und das macht das
auswärtige amt schleswig holstein oder
thüringen haben ja keine außenpolitik
also muss ich das auswärtige amt das von
heiko maas geführte auswärtige amt sein
das hat sein lager berichten nicht
verändert trotz des truppenabzugs und da
muss man nun auch nicht so super clever
sein um zu sagen wenn
die amerikanischen und nato und
deutschen truppen abziehen dann wird
sich die sicherheitslage verändern sagen
auch alle die flüchtlingsorganisation
die kirchen sagen afghanistan ist das
unsicherste land der welt und der
lagebericht bleibt gleich das ist doch
absurd also muss sich der lagebericht
ändern
dann würden vermutlich die flügel der
bundesregierung die stellt hier die
flüge nicht mehr stattfinden können wie
jetzt auch untersagt vom europäischen
gerichtshof für menschenrechte also der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte untersagt der
bundesregierung afghanistan zu fliegen
also da muss man sich auch mal klar
machen dass da gerade passiert auf
welchem tiefen level wie im moment
agieren und dann kann auch nicht
abgeschoben werden sie haben sich das
genau angeschaut machen auch eine klare
ansage sie wollen auch über
verantwortung
das auswärtige amt und horst seehofer
das anschauen soll ich meine ich bin
bundesliga haben ja auch immer die
möglichkeit sich das noch einmal genau
anzuschauen es gibt auch ein bundesland
das nicht abschiebt also die an die
agierender auch unabhängig ich würde
gern zum thema klimaschutz kommen weil
da wollen sie ja verantwortung
übernehmen das stellen sie auch immer
nach vorne da haben sie sehr klare ziele
wir wollen in afghanistan übernehmen es
ist nicht so dass für die klimaschutz
partei uni sind das nicht aber sie haben
in den letzten tagen sehr wieder für das
thema getrommelt und für massnahmen
getrommelt bei einigen sehr zentralen
fragen allerdings die antworten offen
beispiel ist sind die kosten
da gibt es in 500 milliarden klimapaket
was sie planen 25 milliarden extrem wird
ein vorsorgepaket das sind jetzt nur
zwei beispiele
da kommen unglaubliche summen zusammen
trügt der schein oder sagen sie
tatsächlich wenn es ums klima geht
spielt geld gar keine rolle mehr
nein es ist ein ein- oder logik wir
haben die notwendigkeit zu investieren
wir hatten schon vorher der korona
pandemie eine investitionsschwäche in
deutschland das reiche deutschland hat
nicht genügend investiert nicht genug
für wachstum beschäftigung und eben
zukünftige techniken und
industriestandorte getan
das wird behoben indem wir die
zinssituation nutzen die ist ja bei
nullzinsen also wenn sich der staat geld
leiht muss eher weniger oder das gleiche
geld zurückzahlen muss keine zinsen
zahlen im moment damit investieren wir
haben das durchrechnen lassen
dadurch entsteht eine wahre rarität die
bis zu vier prozent über dem wachstum
sonst liegt ich meine ich bin grün aber
sie kann was ich weiß nein aber es ist
tatsächlich offen dadurch wird
dann steuereinnahmen generiert und habe
ich würde kredit zurückgezahlt
das ist super system das übrigens bejaht
wird von der deutschen wirtschaft von
den deutschen banken von der deutschen
wirtschaftswissenschaft also insofern
ist das klar durchgerechnet und klar
beantwortet während der anlagenbauer und
dafür setzen sich ein enddatum und sagen
irgendwann muss man tatsächlich wieder
zur schuldenbremse zurückkehren ich will
die schulden haben sie behalten nur
schulden macht man auch an der
wirklichkeit und wenn man neue
infrastrukturen aufbaut bahnlinien
saniert die schulen hier macht dann ist
das auch vermögen der öffentlichen hand
also es ist auch eigentum ist eigentlich
gesellschaftliches eigentum und wir
sagen nur das was gesellschaftliches
eigentum in der infrastruktur ist das
darf finanziert werden es gibt nicht nur
schulden in den büchern sondern auch
schulden in der wirklichkeit konsumtive
aufgaben also löhne und gehälter sind
davon nicht erfasst es geht auch um
werte zu schaffen die in der
wirklichkeit bleiben so schaffen wir die
klimaneutrale gesellschaft und dem thema
93 und wohlstand ich will ein geheimnis
verraten
irgendjemand muss es bezahlen und das
verschweigen union spd und fdp
irgendjemand muss ich bezahlen wenn man
sagt die fenster ein bisschen dreifach
verglast sein muss jemand die dreifach
verglaste fenster bezahlen entweder gibt
es zuschüsse vom staat der staat sind
wir alle benutzen die gute bonität die
wir durch unser fleiß erwirtschaftet
haben oder die vermieter oder die mieter
müssen es bezahlen also die anderen
parteien sagen die uns dafür angreifer
ihre privatmeinung und user müssen es
bezahlen heute sitzen zu bleiben gerne
bei sorgen die zahlen ja wie
gesellschaftlich solidarisch aber die
sich irgendwo der frage bezahlt werden
muss ist das nicht kann man alles nichts
und sie bereiten sich darauf vor sie
würden sehr gern und mitregieren es war
auch lange zeit so aus als ginge kein
weg daran vorbei dass die grünen in
einer bundesregierung sitzen jetzt sind
die zahlen andere ist könnte sein dass
sie es nicht schaffen und ich habe einen
interessanten satz von ihnen heute eine
frankfurter allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
gelesen sie haben gesagt noch mal mit
blick auf das spitzenteam und die
kanzlerkandidatin wir haben die
aufstellung so gefunden und jetzt sehe
ich meine aufgabe darin die diese
ausstellung möglichst erfolgreich über
die ziellinie zu bringen geht ihnen
eigentlich manchmal der gedanke durch
den kopf sie könnten diese ziellinie den
einzug ins kanzleramt verpassen und sie
persönlich tragen die verantwortung
dafür
kanzleramt war nie ein selbstzweck er
war es war symbol dafür dass die
gesellschaft nicht mehr von den ehemals
die tragenden parteien union und total
demokratie repräsentiert wird und
insofern haben wir den anspruch ums
kanzleramt zu kämpfen
und vor allem geht es aber darum in die
regierung zu kommen ich meine stellen
sie sich vor jetzt mal negativ
gesprochen was passieren würde wenn wir
weitere vier jahre so agieren würden wie
die letzten 16 jahre in all den großen
bereichen klima gerechtigkeit europa
stillstand und mängelverwaltung können
wir jetzt leider nicht mehr machen
eigentlich traurige vorstellung dass wir
einfach weiter so rum bindungslosigkeit
und geilste ich will das hier zu tun ist
wird im september gewählt ich danke
ihnen heute für dieses gespräch
vielen dank das war unsere zdf
sommerinterview mit dem co vorsitzenden
der grünen in der kommenden woche trifft
theo koll den fdp parteichef christian
lindner und zwar in seiner wahlheimat
berlin
herzlichen dank für das zu schauen und
einen schönen abend